en juillet j'adore le tour de france
donc je mets ma petite radio à fond
j'écoute le tour de france et quand les
français gagnent donc elle me connaît
pas les à la page s'agisse des choses
comme ça à côté de la fille à côté de
moi chérie je vous ai demandé
aujourd'hui pour les téléspectateurs
d'avouer quelque chose que vous faites
et que vous alors julien je sais votre
très cool donc si vous ne la voulez pas
je vais le dire nos matches et je le
dire c'est quoi je suis père gédéon
il ya une cour qui est pas très loin
d'ici oui je n'ai donné deux donc je
jouais moi je vais lire le deuxième à
bon dieu le premier il ya une cour où on
prend un peu l'air certains fument et
puis j'étais allé voir donner un coup de
fil dans la cour on m'a dit antennes
dans une minute et à ce moment là je
m'aperçois que j'ai très envie de faire
pipi ce jour là il y avait deux voitures
garées dans quénard de à qui ça va pas
faire plaisir il y avait un 4 4 et une
super voiture de sport et je me suis dit
comme étaient entre les deux voitures
âgées finalement n'ont pas choisi le 4 4
et la voiture de sport et j'ai fais pipi
sur ma portière de la voiture de sport
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'hésitais entre le quatrième prêtre est
ce que tu as qui est bas et il a pissé
sur votre voiture
non mais c'est pas là moi j'ai fait du
vent dans le fond vestiaires merci vous
avez un truc à vous et valérie eux alors
ce que je fait qu'il ne faut pas faire
part c'est que je laisse tout allumée
chez moi tout le temps toute assez
savante j'ai peine à voir
bah oui je vais le faire chier mais ne
le fait pas c'est aussi vous même
j'aime ma boîte aux lettres est toujours
rempli le prospectus ont toujours en ce
moment plus avec la campagne électorale
et du coup en fonction de l'humeur kojak
mes voisins chez des voisins des
relations compliquées goiset ce que j'ai
un chien edgar qui quand je suis pas là
il aboie tout le temps excusez moi c'est
l'interview notre dame et du coup j'ai
souvent des voisins qui se peignent est
donc en fonction de ce qui est qui se
plaignent le plus je prends tout mais ce
prospectus est tout ce que je trouvais
je bourre leur boîte aux lettres jusqu'à
16 à débord berra bonus à la même ville
où les voiliers mais pas les boîtes aux
lettres
alors là vous allez voir maxime gaylib
avoué un jour j'étais chez moi nous est
d'être aidée j'ai mangé en fait à août
périmés
depuis toujours
j'ai mangé j'ai l'habitude de prendre le
métro et le train à la recherche des
scoops et des informations inavouables
c'est que je porte souvent des écouteurs
je fais croire que j'écoute de la
musique
sauf que j'écoutais absolument pas la
musique je ne mets absolument rien et
j'écoute toutes les conversations
géraldine mener un jour j'ai lu le livre
de vote de poche je me suis arrêté le 19
juin on n'est pas si loin
non oui au début quand j'étais écrivain
j'ai écrit à peu près mais trois quatre
premiers romans déjà déjà ça son lavage
déjà normalement bon c'est bon là on les
cons l'entend pas cette radio
normalement moi j'étais écrivain j'avais
écrit mais trois quatre premiers romans
vas-y ouais je faisais le tour des
librairies
ouais on voir si mon livre a été vendu
ouais et souvent ils se retrouvaient
sous les tables dans les étagères perdu
est donc le premier et je le mettais
devant way ou le rebelle à l'histoire
bah ouais c'était un peu long tour
j'avais adressé les libraires
et avouez vous aviez fait pipi dans la
bouteille de quelqu'un oui mais ça c'est
déjà faire c'est toujours en rapport
avec le baby est arrivé c'est en fait
suivre in log je suis arrivé dans cette
équipe
j'aime bien sortir pendant les pauses
prendre l'air et j'aime bien c'est vrai
faire pipi dehors et je faisais rivero
épique contre les poubelles c'est
vraiment un truc de mec de tf1
je crois que ça apparemment le mot c est
passé entre taux longs que ceux
d'epidaure il ya une note qui a été fait
la tension la direction de h2o pour
qu'on me réf percute d'arrêter de pisser
dans la cour donc j'ai arrêté de piste
dans la cour pardon c'est vous qui
puissiez dans la cour oui mais un jour
il a pissé sur un mec épicé sur sa
voiture alors qu en fait j'adore aller à
la plage quoi j'ai ma petite serviette
bleue la grande serviette et l'été je
vais à la plage
alors moi j'ai mon petit transistor des
années 90 à piles il est tout gris mat
bien qu'une petite ampoule vous me
demandez et donc du coup j'arrive à la
place way admettons isabelle est à la
plage était allongé à la plage annoncent
tour à la plage voilà les allonger à la
place je vais à la plage à l'anchois la
place mais ma petite serviette à côté
d'elle et mon petit transistor riz en
juillet j'adore le tour de france donc
je mets ma petite radio à fond j'écoute
le tour de france et quand les français
gagnent donc elle me connaît pas les à
la page
j'avais des choses comme ça à côté de la
fille à côté de moi elle en moyenne et
un truc ce fléau restaurant pour faire
rire mes camarades alors ça je ne sens
pas du tout
c'est très simple j'adore me même plein
de petits curbans entre les dents qui se
fait comme ça contre un grand nom mais
vous avez recruté vous déteste vraiment
je me bouche les oreilles mais des tout
petits tampons dans les oreilles non des
semblants je fais des concours de
miaulements mais il a des contours de la
connaître et le fraîchement nommé au
helmand avec ses chars et concours mais
vos chasses à un concours ils
s'inscrivent à bonjour toi conte comme
résultat que ça dépend il y avait la
période des amours ça va c'est aussi le
grand prix de formule 1 de monaco
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]